the election next month features a big
local race
eight people are vying for four clark
county school district board of trustees
seats
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how the race may change the
dynamic of the board in the nation's
fifth
largest school district for the approval
of the agenda prepare for a local
election
shakeup i think everybody will be
closely watching
the ccsd board of trustee seats in
districts a
b c and e are open a situation
potentially altering the makeup of the
seven-person governing board
the only incumbent in the race is
current board president
lola brooks since the other three
trustees turn out
definitely it's obviously going to
change because there's going to be
change in
personalities but that's going to be a
good thing eight candidates are
campaigning for the four
spots most speak in favor of a
transition after noticing
issues among members
i think it's a result of some of it is
clashing personalities the
board right now as it stands has a
little bit of a communication problem
with that seeming evident over the
summer during a special board meeting
some women disagreed about an abrupt
adjournment before a vote on the
superintendent's employment
what we're seeing is a level of
dysfunction that is
really harming our students at this
point some say the election
may unify the board i think that we all
have one common goal in mind and that is
the children this moment in time we have
a really unique opportunity to
bring in new energy while dealing with
various issues including the budget
pandemic and distance education there
are some things that we need to do
to be more proactive versus being
reactive
i spoke with each candidate via zoom to
see their full
in-depth interview visit our website
8newsnow.com
reporting in las vegas kristen drummond
8 news now